(inspiring music)
- I'm Danny Chew, and I’m the million-mile man.
I wanna ride bicycles a
million miles over my lifetime.
(gears grinding)
I set the million-mile goal, uh,
sometime when I was in college.
I just fell in love with cycling,
and about the same time, I
created a ride in Pittsburgh
called the Dirty Dozen.
I found out that the longer the
race was, the better I did,
and I won the Race Across
America in 1996 and 1999.
(machine whirring)
So, I was, uh, doin' one of my trips that I do
where I try to do 1,000 miles in one week.
I just got dizzy or something
and veered off to the left
and I'm in the ditch before I know it,
and I can't move anything
below my chest, I can't get up.
To suddenly have that freedom
where I can go anywhere
my legs will take me and have
it taken away in a second,
that was, it was tough to take.
I mean, when I was in that hospital,
I was very depressed those
few weeks after the accident.
(groaning)
So, I'm basically about
seven and a 1/2 months out
from the accident now, and my
condition is amazingly better
than, obviously, compared to
the day after the accident.
I expected to take at least a
year to get my arms big enough
to be able to do a decent
speed on the hand cycle.
I still need about 210,000 miles,
but if I can get up to where I can average
200 miles a week on a hand cycle,
I could still get a million
miles 21 years from now.
I'd be 75 then, and I hope
to live to be at least that.
- That's great, I'm very
proud of you though.
You've come a long way.
- [Danny] When you have a
horrible spinal cord injury
like that, you two choices,
you can just sort of
curl up and you know, be
miserable, or think of it
as a new challenge to tackle,
which is what I've done.
As a paralyzed person,
you're stuck in a wheelchair
most of the time that
you're awake, but at least
when I'm on the hand cycle,
you're not in a wheel chair.
You're on a machine like a bicycle.
So, there's a sense of freedom there
that you get away from the
wheelchair, and it's really nice.
The million-mile goal will
take me a little bit longer
than I originally planned,
but I feel like I owe it
to my fans and the people
that support me that I have to
keep going and, you know,
chasing this million-mile dream.
(cheerful jingling)